[Applause]
so
so our candidates have had their chance
to make that case but what are the
people who will decide their future make
of it we have a simple question for our
audience are you ready audience we
rehearsed this beforehand after what you
have heard
tonight who are you most likely to vote
for as you know you need to press one
and then send if it's rishi sunak and
you need to press two and then send if
it is
liz trust are we all ready
any more questions before we need to do
that everybody knows exactly what
they're going to say and do
away you go
there we go so we have 15 seconds when
people were pressing one for rishi sunak
or two for liz tross and then pressing
pressing send
and then
as if by magic in just a few moments
time we'll find out what our audience
here in the studio thinks about who
should be the next prime minister of
this country worth just pointing out at
this stage that naught point three
percent
of the electorate will decide our next
prime minister which means 99.7 percent
of the electorate will not be doing that
do you think that's fair
yes yes yes why do you think it's fair
gentleman here why do you think it's
fair my ballot paper doesn't say who's
the next prime minister we have a
parliamentary system people voted for
the conservative party and as members
we're electing the leader it happens to
be that that leader becomes prime
minister
this is a basic understanding of
ourselves thank you gentlemen up here
really quickly with a check shirt yeah
it's exactly the same as what labour do
okay when they chose um okay now as with
all things with live television the
technology has crashed
so what we're going to do instead is go
with a show a show of hands instead are
we happy with that yes so will you will
you allow me to say who i think has
probably got more hands
thank you so if you think that rishi
sunak had a better show and as a result
uh would potentially make the better
prime minister of this country can you
put your hand up now ladies and
gentlemen please oh my goodness that
looks to me like an awful lot for mr
sunak who would prefer miss truss as the
next prime minister now
i i wasn't expecting that i have to say
but i think with just keeping your hands
up for mistrust while we should get some
more shots just to show people at home
it looks to me as though mr tsunak
convinced you far more than miss tross
um and i'm sorry sir we're almost out of
time and i have had you let let you have
a couple of goals i think the only thing
that you probably needs to learn from
tonight is to read a bit of shakespeare
i don't know what you think
anyway it's been fantastic to see you
all thank you so much for taking the
time for joining us thank you also to
miss trust and also to mr tsunak they
were amazing thank you very much indeed